this section i have titled follow the
science except when we want you to
follow us and we're just going to
pretend it's because we're talking
science
one of the many executive orders that
biden introduced
president biden on january 21st um
requires masks in national parks many of
you will have
heard this um reports news reports on
this tend to say masks required inside
and outside when in crowded areas like
overlooks
which you know that that would sounds
reasonable that sounds like
yes 100 when you're indoors with
strangers you should be wearing masks at
this point
and um you know in a really crowded
place
on overlooks oh okay sure um
but the actual eo
you can show my screen here for a second
zach um
is this is the executive order on
protecting the federal workforce and
requiring mask wearing
the um second paragraph
accordingly to protect the federal
workforce
and individuals interacting with the
federal workforce and to ensure the
continuity of government services and
activities
on duty or on-site federal employees
on-site federal contractors
and other individuals in federal
buildings and on federal lands
should all wear masks maintain physical
a distance and adhere to other public
health measures as provided in cdc
guidelines
thank you zach so that doesn't actually
specify
that they they're not that you're not
required to wear a mask
if you're um away from people outside
and that
worries me because everyone who spends
any time outside now
and you all should be especially
if i mean you should be in whatever form
you can be but if you're taking walks
right now
i assume anywhere in the world and i
certainly assume anywhere in the united
states
although there may be parts where this
is less so um i can only speak to
portland oregon and from you know very
brief moment last week los
angeles um knows the social pressure
that is is being brought about
by this pandemic those of us like me who
walk around
with a mask in my pocket or depending um
in my hand ready to put on but not on
ready to put on at a moment's notice
should it be necessary get assessed
as if we're all walking around like
sneetches that like th
this is something i was talking about a
lot last summer it's like we are
star-bellied sneetches and sneetches
without
and there are indicators by which tribal
assessments are immediately made
and once made you are slotted into a
whole lot of other things
if you are not wearing a mask some
people's eyes will seem to say and i've
indeed seen some
i have not been involved in any of them
but i've seen some sort of yelling
altercations between people
if you're not wearing a mask that must
mean you also believe all this other
crazy nonsense
um you know red team stuff and
therefore we don't like you and you're
putting me at risk and you know i might
die
you know we quickly end up in hyperbole
and drama and performativity
and it's again anti-scientific
so um the assessment of like oh i get it
you're one of them no i'm i'm not one of
them like i'm not showing you my belly
you can't see if i have a star or not
based on whether or not when i'm outside
i don't have a mask on because guess
what
the science actually says is that
there's almost
no risk of transmission for any of the
variants that we have yet seen for which
there is
our data that you can that this virus is
transmitting outside
look at all of those yes ill-advised
protests massive protests that became
riots you know daily in some places like
portland
last summer into last fall there were no
super spreader events that i know of
those things were happening outside even
with a lot of people
jammed together like that many of whom
were not wearing masks
there was very little viral transmission
this virus is not
spreading that way why probably two
reasons
probably more certainly two reasons one
it's about airflow
and you know just just boundary layers
and if you've got any sort of airflow
this this
the risk of getting the disease and the
risk of the severity of the disease
being high
uh once you get it are both density
dependent on how much virus
virus you were exposed to in the first
place so you get exposed to a little bit
maybe it even provides long-term a
little bit of immunity
to you and i'm not i'm not arguing that
you should go and try to get exposed to
a little bit of it but you know that
might actually be productive
um and you know again in service of just
getting some nuance going
here also vitamin d all right so
airflow and vitamin d you go all right
so are you ready for a bit more nuance
i am okay are you sitting down you're
not sitting
for those of you listening rather than
watching i don't know if you're sitting
down because it's pitch black
in the studio i'm also very short also
she's very short
yeah um no here's the here's the thing i
want to
a let's say that uh
i you know let's hope this doesn't
happen but if we if we're stuck with
covet for good if we just have to learn
to live with covid
then we should develop a
way of taking care of each other
relative to the virus without
um causing undue harm to ourselves
right and lots of things function like
this right the sophistication around
pathogens and washing one's hand and and
you know food service and all of that
these are mechanisms in which there is
shame directed at those
who misbehave and for good reason
because there should be a social penalty
for behaving badly another problem with
the current covid case with
respect to masks functioning as stars uh
on the bellies of sneetches
is that you've got two sides who look at
the other
as you're not taking care of us
right so the one side is saying you're
not keeping us safe from
covid you're gonna spread it to us
because you're not wearing your mask so
put it on all the time broadcast that
you are one of the people who doesn't
want to spread covet
and the other side is saying you're not
taking care of us you're participating
in this authoritarian garbage
these people don't know what they're
talking about they're crashing the
economy and pretending it doesn't matter
you know all of these things and you
know there's a degree of truth in this
those who refuse to wear a mask
are definitely putting other people at
risk and those who are
imagining that if you're wearing a mask
you're a better human and therefore
wearing them all the time is a good idea
are participating in spreading
authoritarian garbage
now the problem the hyper nuanced issue
as we've been saying from the beginning
kova does not appear to transmit
outdoors
but that doesn't mean it couldn't learn
that trick
if it learns that trick how will it do
it it will do it because people are
careless outdoors and therefore some
you know virus that has a little bit of
a an edge in that regard for some reason
or another just
by luck will end up transmitting and
creating more cases and it'll get
built up the way every other adaptation
does so the point is
at the moment we appear to have a gift
that we have
a way to stay away from kovid and make
ourselves healthier
and make ourselves psychologically uh
more sound
and it works but if we treat it
carelessly we could lose it so
i think the right place for that line to
go is exactly where you said
if you're at an overlook outdoors and
it's crowded
you should wear your mask even though
the evidence says you're not going to
get covered there right
why because we have to protect the
loophole that we've got
right and so i want to see and in fact
we've lived by this but
if you are alone or just with people
that you're already in potting with
you should not be wearing a mask right
it's actually
potentially going to create more health
problems for you especially if it's
winter and you're otherwise all covered
up and your face is literally the only
place
that could be exposed to the sun yep you
want to be exposed to the sun
yeah for vitamin d reasons which are
very directly relevant to covet so
what you really want if we could just
take the politics completely out of this
question what you would really want
is for us to have a collective
discussion like the one that you and i
have been having since
uh march
in which we built up a model that would
allow you to know whether somebody was
being an [ __ ]
or whether they were just simply taking
advantage of
a safe situation right in other words
as you pass somebody on the street right
the fact that you pass them on a street
and you don't pull
a mask up is not necessarily bad news
for one thing we can keep each other
safe
i sometimes hold my breath if i'm not
gonna put a mask on to do something i
can hold my breath and know that i'm not
exhaling covid
if i have a three second you know
situation where i pass through somebody
else's uh personal space
if we can pay attention to these things
you know the way we do all sorts of
stuff
about um public health and uh
you know disease transmission then we
don't have to
you know persecute people for doing
things that are actually perfectly safe
and
which they're doing them is not evidence
that they're insensitive it's evidence
that they
have a a good model
that's right that's right um
yeah so if you like i said if you cover
everything
on yourself um while you're outside
you're probably not gonna get covered
that's true but you're also not gonna
get any vitamin d
and um for similar reasons i would
advocate not
hiding yourself under thick layers of
sunscreen we've talked about this before
um there is finally now after years of
some of us
thinking this and talking about it um
beginning to be evidence that slathering
yourself with sunscreen
and therefore reducing the level of
sunlight you get
is actually linked to um some
late life illnesses that yes people who
don't slide themselves in sunscreen
end up with a little bit more skin
cancer i think is the result i didn't go
back and look at this but they're less
likely to die from it and they're less
likely to die of other diseases
and if you understand um the you know
just as with the case of there being a
threshold dose of cova that you need
before you catch the disease there are
nuances
but frankly i don't know what the
mechanism is but it's quite clear that a
short break from the sun
gives you the ability to go back into
the sun
and that one can marshal this
in place of sunscreen and if you do that
then you know does the slight increase
persist my guess would be it doesn't
yeah
i i agree so um in general i guess the
the take home here
i mean there are several but is that i
and i know you as well
are not a fan of reductive solutions to
complex problems
um so i've been preemptively skeptical
of pretty much all of these one word or
one phrase
the single note solutions the pandemic
you know hydroxychloroquine
vitamin d vaccines ivermectin like
really that's like it's just gonna be
the one thing um
that seems like a very unnuanced and
uncareful approach
that said just on that list that i just
gave those four things
two of them at least have incredible
promise
and almost no risk so vitamin d
and ivermectin hypermactin as
potentially prophylactic but
almost certainly useful
in reducing symptoms if you do contract
covet 19
widely available not still under patent
apparently so quite inexpensive um
as as a as a treatment rather than a
you know a vaccine-level prophylactic
for covid
uh is has has huge promise and i want to
say it's just beyond promise like it's
just being used in a lot of protocols at
this point
and there are a lot of papers that that
show um
some you know that are beginning to be
out about vitamin d
um you know the the problem is um
you're better off getting all of your
stuff in the ancestral form
and so better than supplementing if
if you can at all to get out in the sun
and
you know i've heard this thing like well
i live so far north that there's no
chance of
getting enough vitamin d at this
latitude and being healthy during the
winter
guess what people lived far north
before they were vitamin d supplements
now in some cases like in the north
atlantic
they were dealing with that by eating a
diet rich in cod
for instance there are there are
historical solutions to these problems
it is
simply not possible that you need a
novel solution
to an historical to a problem that would
have been a problem for historical
people living
where you were living now if they didn't
have access to your novel solution
because people were just living as well
and one caveat which is i was just about
to make the cover okay but no you go for
no go for it all right the caveat is
that there is no guarantee that
your um predispositions
match their level of solution yes right
actually that's a that's a step beyond
what i was going to say and
um you may not know actually so our um
our dear friend and former student and
also research research assistant on our
book
drew schneiderler um i think we took it
out i think it's not even a footnote
anymore but
exactly this on the question of actually
exactly vitamin d
and historical um living where you do
that
that in the far north pacific northwest
the farther north you go
you're told this thing and his point was
if you are from the population that
lived here
2 or 10 or 15 000 years ago
look to your ancestors wisdom look to
the cultural practices that they retain
and maybe those that ancestral wisdom
will apply to you
even if you are from a different
population as you know as he is even if
you're
anglo living in ancestrally
obviously native american land maybe
their solutions will work and maybe
their solutions are actually particular
to the population um to which they
belonged
usually they won't be but sometimes they
will be and
like you you can just you can you can
decide this
carefully on like a step-by-step basis
without having to
reduce it to a single like wear a mask
wear sunscreen
you know yeah the key is you need the
model
you know so it's perfectly possible for
light-skinned people to for the
ways that dark-skinned people deal with
uv
radiation near the equator to be
insufficient for light-skinned people
faced with the same
hazard and vice versa it's possible for
the solutions that light skin people
have for vitamin d to be insufficient
for somebody with dark skin
if you move far enough north so you've
got to pay attention to those things but
the point is if your model
says here's how vitamin d is produced
right and here's how
i interface with that model i you know
am either advantaged or disadvantaged
relative to vitamin d production
based on melanin content or something
like that you can at least figure out
whether you've got something you need to
correct for
and the ancestral way will do it or it
won't do it
in which case you might do something
[Music]
else
[Music]
you